I'm convinced this lets you do some
really amazing magic so here's what I
needed to do
grab a rule or not or steal another
friend and I want you to draw a
quadrilateral any quadrilateral you like
in fact the more random and like
completely irregular life that you can
make it the better this will be okay
make a reasonable size maybe like half
of your page something like that
George any quadrilateral he wants
I hope you've drawn a arm and your
regular wacky looking quadrilateral that
shoot obey any special properties or
anything like that I hope you got one
different to the person next to you make
sure yours looks very dissimilar for the
person next you then what I want you to
do is I want you to find the midpoints
of every one of your four sides
I'm the midpoint so you may need to do a
bit of measurement in a pinch you could
estimate it that's what I'm gonna do but
it will have a much better effect I
promise if you actually measure that so
find the midpoints and then once you've
found those midpoints I want you to join
them up you've got a new quadrilateral a
new quadrilateral inside your
quadrilateral you've just done midpoints
and it's a completely random
quadrilateral just join love
and if you've got any ability to
construct straight lines and measure
them then you should notice something a
bit suspicious
you're completely random quadrilateral
completely random right it just magic
but what is that that's a parallelogram
you've got a parallelogram in front of
you right no matter what quadrilateral
you tried to draw in fact you don't even
need to draw on a flat piece of paper
these four points don't have to be on
the same plane that could be off we even
skew lines that kind of thing you didn't
even need to I bet all of you drew a arm
a polygon which was kind of nice
behaving very few of you probably true
one like this like that
did you draw it okay if you drew that if
you drew that right and you did midpoint
midpoint midpoint midpoint huh he
doesn't care he's still going to make a
parallelogram right okay so what is
going on what kind of black magic is
happening underneath E and a completely
random shape
go on try and do another one just see if
you can make it look compelling why is
it doing this okay
so there's lots of ways to prove just
one before geometric result but the best
way far away is with vectors okay so
what do you need to do underneath where
you drooled that let's draw a new
quadrilateral I mean you can draw the
same chord level again if you like I'm
gonna basically do the same one but I
want us to construct it in a very
particular way and I'll guide you
through it now if you do have two colors
okay what I want you to do is to redraw
this your quadrilateral but I want you
to pick a pair of signs any pair of
adjacent sides and draw them in the same
color so for instance I'm going to draw
these two in red and I'm gonna draw
these to improve doesn't matter which
adjacent sides you choose but as long as
you two - Jason ones we won't talk to
Jason ones in the other that's all we
need so here's our quadrilateral now
where the vectors come in well you can
think of a vector as sorry you can think
of a quadrilateral as four vectors do
you agree
you've got four things that each have
magnitude and direction yes
now the reason why I've asked you to
pair them off is because way to pair
them up I mean let's give them some
names for instance let's call up let's
call this one hey we'll have two going
off in that direction we'll call this
one big going up in this direction
let's call it's called this one see
okay I've got four vectors that make up
my quadrilateral and please note the
order and I'm direction that I've got my
vectors facing you okay so I don't have
this vector D I don't have facing back
to here I've got it facing down there
okay now think back to what we did just
move our simple vector operations okay
do you notice that because a
quadrilateral is a close to become it's
a closed figure there are no gaps okay
when you do a plus B now I'm not going
to try about any what you're saying I
just want you to see where these
victories where is it on the diagram and
then I want you to compare that with C
plus D look at where that victories you
see where it is okay what is the
relationship between these two sums yes
same why are they the same when you add
vectors together you get a new vector
that's the same as pulling both those
vectors and doing them in series right
well if you do a plus because work here
and that's where you end up that corner
could you see plus D instead you go you
can do D plus C because remember what
it'll matter D plus C and you end up at
the same spot so these two are the same
you still with me fine okay now the next
thing that we did after drawing a random
quadrilateral but as you said midpoints
midpoints okay now in vector terms and
we find or express the midpoints of each
of these vectors think think think
if you want midpoints well you want the
direction to say the same right but you
want the magnitude to be half the length
do you agree with that so it's like each
of these vectors is made up of a pair of
vectors that's sort of strung together
and when you find where those to me
that's going to be the midpoint do you
agree with that so onto this diagram
what I'd like you to add on to them is
on divide up all of your vectors in half
ok so I've got a new one over here right
there's a pair here and each one is half
of a to see that there's half of a and
then there's another one which is half
of it yes and of course half a plus half
a is a right because it's stringing
together as vectors you still end up
here do you agree you think I can do
that for all of the sides so you're
gonna get okay wonderful
now you're like alright cool your fabric
points now what
well again I want you to think about how
the tools you know of vector operations
can achieve this result okay now
remember I'm trying to prove that
apparently you get a pound on the ground
out of this thing okay so think to
yourself what are the ways that you can
prove some quadrilateral is a
parallelogram you did you know your
Euclidean your plan geometry Elias you
you know about sufficiency conditions
improving that things are the same
there's a lot of different ways to do it
here's a way I'm gonna try it okay
rather than actually constructing all
four sides I'm just gonna construct you
I want you to watch the two that I
construct
I'm going to construct this one like
that there's one of the sides and I'm
also going to construct this must be
this one over here okay so my
measurements a bit off but you get that
now I can think of is just asides but I
don't want them that I know that vectors
right so I want to state both of these
as vectors I can have this one facing
that direction or that direction which
direction would you like me to face it I
think I should probably go to the black
now the reason why I mean I can't face
it to the left if I'm one right but
facing to the right makes it easier for
me because I can express this vector in
terms of two other vectors that I know
which two half and half B right there's
half a that gets you up to here and if
you string it together with half B it
takes you over there to the destination
right so this new side that I'm a is
half pain plus 1/2 B hearts just than
just a number just take that factor out
that's half a plus half it do you agree
okay now I have a look at the other side
the other dotted black line that I've
got there right again I can think of it
as the sum of two vectors which two
vectors Hoffy and I've seen which I can
add in any order I live in right so I'm
just gonna write it as half C plus half
D is that okay with you done
okay very hard in a second hold on right
at the beginning as soon as we drew this
and named the signs as vectors you told
me that a plus B equals C plus D right
you told me that those are the same so
therefore just take this equation right
just multiply both sides by
you just multiply both sides by 1/2 and
it tells you this what does that mean
what does it mean we're vectors are
equal to each other
when vectors are equal it means their
Direction is the same and their
magnitude is the same now we're not used
to speaking those terms when you're
doing like a plain geometry proof we
would much rather say that the sides
have the same direction so they're
parallel and they have the same
magnitude which means they're equal in
length and guess what if you have a
four-sided figure and it's opposite
sides are both parallel and equal guess
what kind of shape it is it has to be a
parallelogram
it has to be now is that an elegant
proof or what look two lines right that
puts so little you know your plane
geometry proofs back in an earlier year
a bit to shame right because vectors
take care of all the geometry for you
they just turn it into addition and
subtraction and multiplication
super-easy
not a Coghlan saying would train one
side okay so pretty neat once you have
the right tools okay
just like rectangular form and pull the
form you use the right tools for the job
and like how else would you do this by
the way how else rhetorical question
how else could you prove this there are
there are lots of nice ways to do it but
none of them are as quick or as elegant
as this one so that's why I really like
it